Hi, my name is Neerja Aggarwal.
I'm a graduate student here
at MIT in the physical optics
and electronics lab.
Our lab is trying to do
noninvasive diagnostics using
spectroscopy.
Raman spectroscopy
is a technique
in which you shine
laser light at a sample
and measure the
scattered photons.
Now, this gives you a spectral
fingerprint of the molecule.
Clinical trials
have already shown
this to be an effective
technique for cancer
diagnostics, but we need
a way to develop and test
new instruments in
the laboratory setting
before jumping to
expensive clinical trials.
During my master's
research, I showed
that you can use an
in vitro skin tissue
culture as an optical
substitute for human skin
instead of jumping
to clinical trials.
I showed that the
skin tissue culture
has similar Raman,
autofluorescence,
and optical properties
as human skin
with more than 25
volunteers as comparison,
making it an
invaluable R&D tool.
Now, another challenge
with this technique
is that you're measuring
a really small Raman
signal on top of a large
autofluorescence background.
I looked at ways to separate
these two signals in time
using time-correlated
single photon counting,
thereby improving the
signal to noise ratio.
Now, Raman
spectroscopy is already
undergoing commercialization,
and these two results
will accelerate the product
development process,
bringing it closer to patients.